outriders is a game that isn't defined
by big new ideas
but a variety of familiar elements mixed
together in experimental ways
it's a role-playing game with loot
shooter elements it's a serious dark
sci-fi story with a big dose of
goofiness and humor
it's a cover shooter that demands you
rush out and smash enemies with
ludicrous superpowers
whether this mixture works for you will
determine how much you'll enjoy it
[Music]
though outriders looks like a loot
shooter live game
it's actually much more mass effect 3
than destiny 2.
like in mass effect rpg progression and
cover shooting are much more important
than chasing the next new gun
outriders is a cover shooter rpg with a
hearty dose of gear progression
leaning heavily into an epic story told
with tons of dialogue cut scenes and
collectible lore
developer people can fly draws a lot
from its past work on the gears of war
series
rifle-toting enemies take fortified
positions to unload on you at a distance
backed up by shotgunners that try to
close the gap armored troops with chain
guns plotting in the open
and cleaver wielding sprinters who
charge straight at your face to drive
you out of cover
the core of outriders is shooting and
you'll have a mess of guns at your
disposal
though you can only have two main
weapons and a sidearm equipped at any
given time
you'll have lots of options thanks to
the loot shooter half of the outrider's
formula
that means you can pair a sniper rifle
with a shotgun or assault rifles with
smgs
and since you're constantly searching
for weapons with better stats
you'll cycle through a lot of different
loadouts in a short amount of time
what makes these guns especially fun are
the myriad different properties and
status effects they can have
like dispensing poison blowing enemies
up freezing people solid
and so on recalling gears of war again a
writer shooting reliably feels good
but finding synergies between your
weapon's weird properties
is a lot of what makes the shooting part
of the game rewarding
things get a bit weirder as outriders
merges space superpowers with its cover
shooter core
you could choose from one of four
character classes early in the game
devastator trickster pyromancer or
technomancer
these each have the general roles of
tank rogue
damage focused mage and debuff focused
mage the devastator uses gravity attacks
for close range kills
the trickster teleports around to get
the drop on enemies
the pyromancer is a mid-range fire
flinger and the technomancer can summon
turrets and rockets
that also poison or slow targets each
class has a different way of
replenishing health through combat
generally by focusing on their specific
strengths the devastator for instance
heals you for every close range kill
encouraging you to get in close to
enemies to hit them with powers like a
small earthquake
combat becomes a constant calculus
between when to cut the distance and
take down an enemy
and when to take cover bide your time
and protect yourself
that combination can be a bit confusing
and as a result
combat is a place where outriders can
both sprint and stumble
you're playing a shooter where you use
cover to keep yourself alive
but you're encouraged to leave cover to
keep yourself alive
that push and pull of avoiding incoming
damage and taking the fight to the enemy
means that you constantly have to be
managing the battlefield
as well as your ability cooldown timers
if you jump out of cover and go wild
with all your powers on an approaching
enemy
you leave yourself exposed for all their
friends and quickly find yourself cut
down by incoming fire
that means that having an earthquake
ready to stun incoming fighters is
essential to saving your life
since it allows you to grab kills while
keeping your head down
similarly abilities like the trickster's
teleport which instantly puts you behind
enemies who are in cover
are just as useful for dramatically
repositioning yourself across the
battlefield
as they are for eliminating foes but you
can rarely just go
all out with your guns and abilities you
really have to think about where you are
where your enemies are and how you can
best eliminate them without exposing
yourself
it can feel unintuitive for a while but
when you do find the balance between
using your powers
healing yourself and staying out of fire
outriders can create some pitched
frantic battles that use cover just
enough to give you a second to breathe
without nailing your shoulder to a
single chest high wall
and leaving you there for minutes on end
but there are also times when you'll
find yourself surrounded or cut off
trapped between enemies unable to kill
anything fast enough
or escape the onslaught to save yourself
sometimes a situation will just feel
unwinnable
but luckily outriders generally sets you
back only a bit when you die
so you can re-enter a fight quickly and
try a new approach
facing tougher altered enemies who have
power similar to yours
can result in battles of attrition where
you have to cheese the situation
by scurrying out of the arena so enemies
don't all chase you down at once
sometimes even careful management of
powers cover and your spacing on the
battlefield
aren't enough to save you and it's these
moments when outriders can get
frustrating
because it doesn't feel like you're
losing for lack of skill there are ways
to deal with that issue
outriders is largely pretty open and has
liberal fast travel
so you can bail on a mission and go do
side quests to grab rewards that can
boost your gear and character
the difficulty of enemies is also
determined by your overall
world tier level which rises as you earn
experience points alongside your
character level
world tier also determines loot drops so
there is an incentive to keep it on the
highest level you can
but if you're in a particularly annoying
fight you could always back it down a
touch to keep yourself from stalling
the world tier is a smart solution to
the difficulty problem
and since it can be adjusted anytime it
gives you a lot of freedom to avoid
frustration
at key moments i'm only about 10 or so
hours into outriders
so it's difficult to say how all its
elements gel over the long term
so far though i'm intrigued by the way
it blends disparate ideas together to
create new flavors
while the combat can be tough to wrap
your head around it first the frenetic
balancing
act has created some heart-pounding
moments more fun
and intense battles than annoying ones
you can also play almost all about
riders cooperatively
which seems like it could go a long way
toward lessening combat irritations
and while i haven't had a chance to team
up with anyone else yet i can already
see how powers
abilities and gear might work together
on teams
to create fun synergies outrider's story
also has me pretty hooked in
people can fly has obviously put a lot
of time and thought into the game's lore
and there's a lot of interesting writing
to be found in journal entries and side
quests
what i'm liking most though is the
unexpected mixture of desperation
and humor the planet enoch is a war-torn
hellscape where the last vestiges of the
human race
are literally ripping each other apart
the misery and torment of the situation
is made worse by the altered
like your character who basically have
gained godlike power
how those people choose to use that
power is an ongoing moral question
and i'm interested in the way the game
is attempting to explore it
coupled with the dark serious and gritty
sci-fi take though
are the moments of levity that make
outriders characters feel human
side missions in particular have you
interacting with weird characters
like a drug-addled military commander or
a vinyl loving collector of earth
artifact
and your character's attitude is almost
always one of vague but funny annoyance
at doing their small scale favors
come on get out of there you out of your
mind
i'm leaving this your [ __ ] out until the
sun's all the way up
i'm not waiting around here for the sun
to come out there are a lot of these
moments where outrider strikes a
delicate balance between
being serious and being light developing
its world and recognizing that it's
dealing in some
fairly absurd concepts these moments
likely won't land for everyone
it can feel a touch edge lord at times
although rarely so far
and the tone can ping-pong between
extremes especially jumping off the main
quest to explore side content but those
swings are also where
outriders excels if you meet it where it
is its story is often funny but
similarly intense its combat requires
you to take cover and to charge
its abilities make you phenomenally
powerful but prone to overestimating
yourself
if you can find the balance in outriders
the rpg shooter finds ways to combine
well-worn video game ideas
into something new and fun whether those
new combinations will carry it all the
way through its seemingly expansive run
time
remains to be seen but i'm excited to
see what still waits in the wilds of
enoch
and to smash it with seismic earthquake
magic
[Music]
foreign